this is an intelligent automated system
how can I help you today I just like to
check the status of my order no no no I
just want to check the status of my
order no cancel I want to check the
status of my order all right welcome to
take 5 don't you wish that building
intelligent useful chat box was easier
sounds to me like you want to talk more
about dialogue flow that's right give a
demo - oh yeah let's go ahead and jump
right in
here we have the dialogue for counsel so
let's go ahead and create a new agent
we'll go ahead and call it take five
demo we will select a language English
for now but you see we have many options
and we'll also select the time zone
finally we'll attach this to a DC Butte
project and we'll just create a new one
for now now though our agent has been
created let's go ahead and define some
intense but before we do let's look at
some of our pre-made intents that were
created automatically with our agent we
have first our fallback intent and also
our welcome intent let's dive a little
deeper into our fallback intent this
intent will catch anything the bar does
not understand and respond accordingly
here there's no need to add any training
data but but we can edit how the bar
will respond to our users by default we
have some examples here on the screen
essentially can you repeat that again or
hey I didn't catch that let's go ahead
and go back to the main screen and look
at our default welcome intent here the
body is looking for users input such as
hi hello hey there or any other type of
greeting and will automatically respond
with its own greeting as you can see
here to make things a little interesting
let's go ahead and edit the text of the
response and half the chat bot actually
asked for the user's name as part of
that greeting so here we'll go ahead and
add what's your name
to every single option
now let's add some common greetings that
the user may enter such as hi hello and
a couple of other examples as well this
way the chat bot knows exactly what to
expect before it gives us its phrases
now the great thing about dialogue flow
is that you just need to give it a few
examples and then dialogue flow will go
ahead and extrapolate for you we
recommend at least using 10 examples so
the dialogue file can get an idea of the
kind of things that it should expect
before it gives its phrases and once we
have done this we'll go ahead and click
Save now from an intent we can also add
a follow-up intent as you can see we
have a bunch of default options you
could pick but for this example go ahead
and pick the custom option and now that
we've selected it let's go ahead and
dive into it the first thing we're gonna
do is edit the name and the name of this
intent we'll just call it saying hi now
just like we did before we'll go ahead
and add some training phrases since at
this point the bot just asked us our
name we'll go ahead and give dialogue
flow different examples of different
ways that someone may say their name as
an example here I'll put just the first
name and you'll see that as I add
examples dial flow will automatically
identify that I put a first name a last
name and even when I add other words
such as my name is or they call me or I
go by dialogue flow we'll still be able
to identify which part of the sentence
is the name and we do this by using our
natural language processing if at any
point dialog hole does not catch any
particular name you can simply select
that word and then tell dialog so that
that is a name that way you're making
sure that that flows understanding the
context of the input that the user is
actually giving now as we scroll to the
bottom we can actually add the responses
that the button will give and we'll have
our bot say hello and thank you for
chatting with me but since we want this
to be a little bit more personalized
we're actually gonna include the first
name input of the user that was
originally given to us and we do this
simply
by adding a dollar sign and then saying
given name this will make sure that
whatever the given name input was we're
using for our output from the chat pod
and then we'll go ahead and click Save
so now that we build a pretty simple
robot let's go ahead and look at a quick
demo we'll go ahead and go to the
integration section where you see we can
integrate with a bunch of different
partners and we'll go ahead and click on
web demo and here we have our chat bot
life so we'll go ahead and say hi to it
really quickly and we're prompted
automatically to say our name and then
we'll give it a brand new name that it's
never seen before so here output and
Riki quizzes it's an example and they're
automatically captured my name and I was
able to say hi back to it
even though I had never seen that name
before I know this is a really simple
demo of dialogue flow but just now
imagine the possibilities making a
decision tree with different intents and
different actions prompting users for
different inputs and then tying in a
back-end that can have actionable
requests this is just the surface of
what dialogue for can do so if you wanna
build a great chat bot instead of what
you should be using dialog box yep and
then less than five minutes you can be
up and running please like and if you're
working on any cool projects please
click on the link below
[Music]